AstraZeneca may be able to help.
>>SAN FRANCISCO STATE'S
ATTORNEY AND MY FRIEND RECENTLY
DECIDED TO REPRESENT A MAN WHO
SAID HE WAS UNLAWFULLY FIRED BY
GOOGLE FOR EXPRESSING HIS
CONSERVATIVE VIEWS AFTER HE
WROTE A MEMO CRITICIZING THE
COMPANY'S DIVERSITY
REQUIREMENTS.
THEY BOTH JOIN US NOW TO DISCUSS
THE LATEST WITH THE CASE.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
I KNOW YOU TOOK THE CASE TO THE
NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS BOARD.
BUT YOU TOOK THE CASE THERE.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> SO JAMES FILED A CASE WITH
THE NLRB THE DAY HE WAS FIRED.
SO IT HAPPENED BEFORE HE GOT
DOWN
DOW
COW
COUN
COUNSE
COUNSELE
COUNSELED
COUNSELED.
AND THE NATIONAL LABOR ACT
IMPLEMENTED BY THE BOARD
PROTECTS -- IT FALLS UNDER THAT
CATEGORY THAT HE COMPLAINED
ABOUT.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S
PROTECTED UNDER THE NLRB?
>> AND SO WE ALSO GOT GEARED UP
FOR A LAWSUIT.
SO THE NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD HAS A NUMBER OF REGIONAL
OFFICES AND THEY DECIDED THAT
JAMES HAD A CASE.
NOW, WHEN SOMEBODY'S FIRED,
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO ACT QUICKLY
WITHIN WEEKS TO HAVE A HEARING
AND GET THEM RETURNED TO THEIR
JOB.
SO WE WERE WAITING AND THEN
FINALLY WE REALIZED SOMETHING'S
GOING ON.
IT TURNS OF THE GOOGLE LOBBIED
THE WASHINGTON OFFICE OF THE
NLRB.
>> WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
NO-NO.
THE BIG HEAVY PUSH FROM GOOGLE
ON THE NLRB.
AND THIS IS A TRUMP APPOINTEE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT.
THE PRESIDENT APPOINTED THE
DEPUTY GENERAL COUNSEL ANDING
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
OBAMA HOLDOVERS AT THE NLRB
DECIDED TO OVERRULE.
>> DOES IT HAPPEN OFTEN?
>> IT REALLY DOESN'T HAPPEN
OFTEN.
>> OKAY.
SO, JAMES, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
THIS HAS BEEN QUITE A ROLLER
THIS HAS BEEN QUITE A ROLLE
THIS HAS BEEN QUITE A ROLL E
THIS HAS BEEN QUITE A ROLL ER
THIS HAS BEEN QUITE A ROLLER
COASTER FOR YOU?
YOU'RE NOW THIS CONSERVATIVE
FOLK HERO.
YOU LOVED YOUR JOB.
YOU LOST YOUR JOB.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING AND DOING
THROUGHOUT THIS?
>> IT'S A LITTLE EXHAUSTING.
>> WERE YOU A CODE WRITER?
OKAY.
SO I IMAGINE YOU COULD GET HIRED
BY SOMEONE ELSE AT THIS POINT.
ARE YOU WORKING FOR SOMEONE
ELSE?
>> I'M STILL LOOKING.
>> YOU'RE STILL LOOKING.
>> THIS HURT HIM.
>> GOOGLE IS THE 800-POUND
GORILLA AND PEOPLE ARE AFRAID OF
IRRITATING GOOGLE.
SMALLER COMPANIES DON'T WANT TO
--
>>WE WITHDREW THE NLRB CHARGE
WHEN WE REALIZED THEY'RE GOING
TO SIT ON IT AND NOT TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
WE FILED A LAWSUIT IN STATE
COURT.
WE'RE WAITING FOR OUR FIRST DAY
IN COURT, WHICH WILL BE IN MAY.
>> WHAT DOES THIS SAY TO OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE WORKPLACE, WHETHER
YOU'RE A CONSERVATIVE WORKING IN
A LIBERAL PLACE OR A LIBERAL IN
A CONSERVATIVE ENVIRONMENT?
>> YOU AND I WENT TO LAW SCHOOL
TOGETHER.
AND IN COURT YOU HAVE A
SUPPOSEDLY NEUTRAL JUDGE.
BUT A JUDGE HEARS BOTH SIDES AND
THERE'S EVIDENCE TAKEN AND A
DECISION-MAKING.
A LOT OF FACELESS BUREAUCRATS
MAKE VERY IMPORTANT DECISIONS
ABOUT POLICIES.
WHAT GOOGLE EMPLOYEES DON'T KNOW
IS GOOGLE IS ACTIVELY LOBBYING
THE NATIONAL LABOR BOARD.
>> THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
I HAVE NOT HEARD THAT BEFORE.
AND GOOGLE IS BIG, BUT YOU STILL
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE LAW.
WE'RE OUT OF TIME.
BUT A SURVEY OF SILICON VALLEY
EMPLOYEES, IF YOU'RE
CONSERVATIVE, 89
CONSERVATIVE, 8
CONSERVATIVE, 74
CONSERVATIVE, 74%
CONSERVATIVE, 74% SA
CONSERVATIVE, 74% SAY
CONSERVATIVE, 74% SAY T
CONSERVATIVE, 74% SAY THE
CONSERVATIVE, 74% SAY THEY'
CONSERVATIVE, 74% SAY THEY'RE
HESITANT OF BEING THEMSELVES AT